the following is my conversation
with my new friend
mr goose
um
he doesn't
he's quite shy
quite distant but underneath there
is a depth that i
would love to explore just
i was wondering if you can
tell me about art
what what do you think is beautiful in
this world
how do you think of beauty
and everything you've seen on these
trails
and everything you've eaten
what do you find beautiful
what do you think of bukowski you said
to do a dangerous thing with style
that's what i call art
you clearly have style
the way you're distant makes me
long for your attention
i feel like that's a precondition
for being a great artist where are you
going
i'm sorry
i'm sorry i didn't prepare for this
conversation as much as i could have
you can't always run away
from yourself
i hope you find what you're looking for
mr goose
i hope you find it
in those uh
green bushes
your heart
pushes you toward
or out there in the sea
take care of yourself mr goose thank you
thank you for uh at least giving me a
chance
goodbye